Hey youtubers it’s charlie and this week
on Arrow we got to watch Roy’s rocky quality
training montage, minus the tube socks.
And we got a nice teaser for the suicide squad.
Just like last week I’ll be doing a new
arrow q&a video tomorrow so write any questions
you want me to include in the comments.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ll try to get it up by tomorrow night.
We’ve got a lot to get through and I’m
trying to post this before I hit a hundred
thousand subscribers to let’s do our top
5 moments and then I’ll do my review.
Number 5 - Sideways skinclaw wolverine reference.
This is the DC universe, but did anyone else
get a wolverine vibe when that man started
digging Bronze tiger’s claws out of his
skin.
We saw all the claws come out, but what about
the hinge he fastens them to?
I think that’s what he had hidden in his
legs.
Without those, the blades are just sharp knives.
Number 4 - All of the Malcolm Merlyn Shoutouts.
For an episode that did not feature John Barrowman,
the characters mentioned Merlyn a lot.
I kept expecting him to show up in the end
teaser.
He’s got to come back sometime, so I’m
guessing next week’s League of Assassin’s
episode.
Bonus high fives for the Tommy shoutout.
I’ve seen a lot of you ask if I think he’s
ever coming back, but all I have as evidence
of that is this behind the scenes picture
stephen amell posted to his facebook page.
So maybe they filmed a scene for this episode
and it just got cut during the edit.
Number 3 - Drunk Laurel.
This is really that last scene.
But I knew her going off the deep end was
going to be what oliver used to bring black
canary back.
So when he made that phone call in the bar
I had a feeling it was to her.
She’s back in the next episode and nyssa
al ghul is coming to get her.
It sounds like they had a relationship.
I wonder who’s the oliver and who’s the
felicity in that situation.
Number 2 - It’s really more of a Squad.
We finally got our first official suicide
squad shoutout.
The writers had been talking about it since
comic con but it took half a season to get
there.
I’m predicting that we’ll see them on
a mission for ARGUS before the season finale
this year.
And they’ll definitely be part of season
3.
I don’t think we’ll see harley quinn any
time soon though.
So don’t expect the exact same roster from
the comic books.
Number 1 - Do you have one of your hoodies?
Do you even have to ask.
Best moment of the episode.
A lot of you guys have asked me which version
of Roy I think he’s going to be on the show.
It doesn’t look like they’re training
him to use arrows.
So I don’t think that he’ll be the red
arrow, but I do think they’ll make a lot
of ‘red’ jokes.
And that hoodie will probably be his uniform
for the rest of the season.
I predict that during the season finale in
the aftermath of whatever ends up happening
that Oliver will give him a real red leather
uniform like his green arrow costume.
Honorable mention goes to Felicity’s Bronze
tiger joke at the beginning of the episode.
It wasn’t the best moment of the episode,
but it was the funniest.
What a stupid name, Tigers aren’t bronze.
Let me know what your favorite moment was.
Suicide Squad, Roy joining team arrow or the
island scenes.
Overall I give the episode a solid A minus.
If Oliver hadn’t revealed himself and brought
roy into team arrow I would have given it
a B plus.
I give extra points for aggressive pacing.
In case you missed them there was a tease
for slade’s son Joe.
That’s Jerico in the teen titan comics.
He’s got his own super powers, so I’m
really interested to see if Jerico comes on
the show next year.
I’m not expecting him to make an appearance
this year.
That would be a really cool storyline for
Slade next year.
It would be like Tommy and Malcolm Merlyn
situation.
I’m glad the drunk laurel arc is going to
resolve itself quickly, I don’t know if
the subsequent redemption arc for her will
mean becoming the true black canary or if
she’ll just clean herself up.
Right now I’m really digging Caity Lotz
as the canary, so I don’t want her to leave
the show just yet.
In case your listening arrow writers.
The only other good reference I caught including
Milo Armitage the arms dealer.
In the comic books he was the grandfather
of the Conor Hawke green arrow.
Let me know if you saw any references that
I didn’t mention.
But the big ones were red arrow, the suicide
squad and Jericho.
Remember to post your questions for my Q&A,
I hope the Jerico name drop helps you develop
a few theories about future storylines.
Be sure to subscribe to get that video.
I’ll try to post it by tomorrow night.
I’m just passing one hundred thousand subscribers
as I’m posting this video.
So thank you so much for being awesome everyone.
I made a special thank you video that I’ll
post on thursday though.
Right now click here for my Q&A and click
here for last week’s arrow episode.
Thanks so much again, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!